this full service pit stop took 16.6
seconds with 72 steps to complete
just restriking one lug nut takes on
average three tenths of a second
let's take a look at the footage in slow
motion
[Music]
carrier's getting his equipment set
right out of the gate just like the [ __ ]
man's getting his jack ready on the wall
as well that jack itself weighs about 35
pounds and of course the changers have
their guns already in the off position
they're always making sure the button's
in the right position they have nitrogen
running through that air hose so that
gun itself works when they jump off the
wall
one of the biggest things we teach is
always to jump on time so these hickory
members are all moving as you see in
sync off the wall each position has the
same steps just to get to the right side
and that is on the clock they have to
meet these times of getting to their job
for changers that's getting to their
first lug nut for the jack person is
getting to the peg of the car for the
fuel it's getting the probe to the dry
break of the car tire carriers are
having to get these two tires as you see
here in the clip out to the right side
while jumping in between the jet person
and the changer getting those tires that
weigh over 90 pounds each setting them
out on the right side and having to get
to that right rear of the car and then
putting that tire on the car one thing
we always talk to our pit crews about is
don't try to speed something else up for
something you've already done wrong make
sure you maintain your pace throughout
the whole course of the pit stop forget
what you just did bad pick up from there
and repeat that process it still will be
a slower stop but it won't turn into
quicksand
so here we're showing a good example of
choreograph you're always trying to
chase that choreograph to make it
cleaner there's always a one percent
that we can make better and better for
each stop that front changer's always
taking five steps to get to his first
lug nut the jackman has taken five steps
to clear the nose of the car to be
squared up on the right side to hit his
peg the rear changer's taking his same
three steps to get around the car drop
in to get his socket into that hub
they're getting square to the car which
is something you always want to be that
means your hips are facing your target
that allows your torso everything else
to be facing your target changers that's
crucial because it's a precision based
element trying to hit these lug nuts off
five for five on all their patterns and
jackman had to put this plate that's
about five inches wide on a peg that's
about an inch wide and make sure that
things always center mass when it's
coming in that jab plate starts to get
low low low low getting that whole body
of the jack getting down so you can go
and start placing that plate before the
car itself stops that's a 3 500 pound
car that we're getting up with a single
stroke
here on the right side the tire
exchanges are really good they basically
hit that fifth lug nut off pull tire get
the tire on hit the first sliding on is
about two seconds and that's called the
exchange that is a big chunk of both
sides of the pit stop these changers
only get two tenths or under on the
front to get to their first lug and the
rear changer is only getting about seven
tenths of a second to get to their first
slug so this is a great view of the
front changer he's popping each lug nut
efficiently that socket's hitting the
lug square getting them off on the first
strike
does a really excellent job as soon as
you clear that fifth lug nut we've got
to go ahead and start flipping the gun
so we can get both hands into the wheel
the left hand is still holding the gun
as you'll see in this angle so you don't
have a full grip like you do on your
right hand but we teach to get those top
two fingers that index that middle
finger hooked on the spoke closest to
seven or eight o'clock and that right
hand closest to two or three o'clock so
we got a nice symmetrical lever coming
off the hub good pulls here changers
again really saving time on button
switches these button switches can take
anywhere from two tenths to a second if
they miss it and so if you can shave
eight tenths on a bad button switch on
both sides of the car that's another 1.6
seconds in the pit stop that they're
going to save just off of using their
equipment more functionally so that's
those pieces of the pit stop we're
always looking at so we can grade them
out once they get back from the race
track
if you watch that tire carrier in the
rear you watch the jab person in the
front starting to put those tires on
you'll see there's two different styles
here the right rear is being what we
call left stepped on and the right front
tire is being swung on so it's two
styles of carrying a swinging index is
always going to be a little bit faster
than a left step index due to
biomechanics on how you set up and using
your hips to put the tire on the car
you'll see him just get his left hand
placed on the tape for his hand
placement and you'll start to see that
right hand go set up close to six
o'clock that way you can start to move
the tire on with his right leg we call
that more of a swing stout index so he
is swinging the tire on and of course
that tire carrier is left stepping the
tire on
we always say a four tower pit stop is
two stops within itself the right side
and the left side front changer does a
really great job bracing himself on the
fender to get up he's always getting his
hips angled at 45 degrees coming around
the nose of the car chat person is
dropping that car after he sees that all
five lug nuts are tight on the right
side as soon as he's dropping that jack
he is chasing that front changer we're
always working in unison so that front
changer is taking three steps to get to
the left side that jack person is taking
seven steps to get to the left side rear
changers taking five steps to get to the
left side and in the tire carrier
they're trying to take minimal steps to
get to that right rear tire that just
got tire pulled the tire carrier here
does a great job of moving that 90-pound
tire efficiently to the left side he's
also making sure that tire gets back to
the wall if tires don't get back to the
wall that's a tire penalty on the pit
crew but you also have to have a really
great front changer getting up already
having that tire out of the way getting
his gun up getting that hose cleared so
he can get up and go and here's a great
angle of him getting that out of the way
taking his three steps getting back down
getting that gun in the hub generally
that time's only about two seconds to
2.2 seconds from getting up and getting
back down and starting her job again so
here's another example of what we don't
want to have false steps that tire
carrier every step he takes needs to
always be in a forward direction the pit
crew that's the story of their lives
every step they take needs to be going
towards the next objective of the pit
stop and if they're doing that that [ __ ]
person can get faster from what we call
peg to peg dropping that car running
around the car like you see here getting
the plate under the left side peg and
pegging it that peg to peg on a good day
is under three seconds and then getting
the car up is well below four seconds
and if all things go good changers
already hit five off on the left rear
nothing happened on the front for the
jet person to run around he's able to
get that tire onto the left side
generally about five and a quarter
seconds to five flat and that's pushing
the boundaries of how fast you can
really go
here we have a great view of the chat
men placing that jack under the peg
pegging that efficiently using a jack
that will get these cars and trucks off
the ground within one pump shop jacks
you might have at your house might take
three or four pumps to get the lift to
max capacity so when you have a
hydraulic you can get the car off the
ground with one it's going to take a lot
more force so we're always teaching them
how to use their hips to not only just
peg the car but to drive up the handle
and then force all their weight through
the back of that lever using the maximum
amount of weight they can to drive the
car up in one solid stroke we generally
get the car up in one second or less
because we have to go ahead and get the
tires off efficiently sooner than later
one thing that makes a pit crew and a
pit stop different than a lot of sports
is mostly sports you're not carrying
such heavy equipment and being timed
with it we're using what we call hinging
where you're lifting weight lowering
weight with the hips you don't see them
rounding their low back to actually put
the jack under the car or to put the
tire on the car we don't teach to be
fast by timing that pit stop we teach
them to be fast by taking out extra
steps we always call it hip knee toe so
start pointing your hip where you're
going to go point your knee where you're
going to go and then get that big toe
underneath you and drive out of the hole
the rear changer is going to the left
which is to the rear of the car but to
get up more efficiently because we have
to run around a little bit bigger of a
dimension in the rear versus the front
we do this thing called a post step
where that tire changer as soon as he
hits five lug nuts on and he's done
he'll go ahead and switch that button
and get that right leg underneath him so
he can drive out of the car there that
allows him to be super fast getting up
and allows him to keep what we really
want to see is that 45 degree body lean
where he's not standing straight up
losing time vertically and he's not also
just stretching around the car which
would lose linear speed so there's a
really good angle of hitting those studs
hitting those lug nuts off in the front
with his impact wrench and that socket's
lining up if they ever have to do a
re-strike it's generally because they've
done something to affect the angle of
the socket it could be they didn't have
the camber in their wrist they could
have their elbows dropping to push that
gun high they could have been rising up
in her hips to push the gun down you'll
also see in the same shot that we did
have a re-strike on the rear changer
thought he had cleared that lug nut he
had to go back in and hit it off again
and you'll see there's a big difference
in time when you hit five off versus
having to go back and re-strike that six
lug nut you'll also see there's pit
support here and these are the people
who work behind the wall they're just as
important as the pit crew when it helps
getting the pit stop to be more
efficient they do things like pull hoses
roll tires in hand off second fuel cans
this is an angle where the pit support
is actually rolling in the left rear
tire it's faster for that jack person to
be able to come around to the left side
of the car and already have that tire
set up to the left rear so he can just
grab it and start to index it if that
pit support is not there then that jab
person would have to peg pump the left
side up run back to the wall grab the
tire and get back into position and
index it on the left side which as you
can tell would take a lot of time
these tire carriers putting those tires
on the hub really quickly with their
left hand always being on the same spoke
and then using their right thumb to
steer that tire to the stud you just
don't grab the wheel and just throw it
on any way they're lining up those five
stud holes to the five studs that are on
the hub these changes are timed on how
quickly they can do that and on average
they're doing five lug nuts off or five
lug nuts installed within one second to
1.2 seconds and if you time and look at
the best indexes on pit road on sunday
saturday and friday these tire carriers
and jab persons are moving that tire
from the ground and getting it lined up
on the hub flush within a half a second
and we have those tapes on tire to help
us always have the same hand references
you want to hit 20 lug nuts every stop
even if you have extras that's fine what
you don't want to do is have 20 lug
strikes and be perfect on your patterns
but then you have three four five loose
lug nuts where you have a loose wheel
same thing with a fueler putting fuel in
the car you can put that probe to a dry
break and engage it but if that thing's
not perfectly sealed fuel's not gonna
get in the car this is a good example of
when a fueler is coming from the wall on
their first can plugging in and once
they have that can in their hands right
hand wrapped around it left hand
supporting the neck of that probe they
take that left foot right foot left foot
to engage the car and then using those
hips keeping them at 45 degrees using
that left hip really to engage the probe
to the dry break of the car to make sure
there's a flush seal of the can so fuel
starts to flow
so the big thing we need to do before
the race and during the race is we have
to clean these wheels get any kind of
debris off the actual stud holes
themselves degrease them and then what
we do after that is we glue the lug nuts
on we use a weather strip adhesive that
goes to the back of the lug nut just
enough to stick it to the steel itself
of the wheel and then we'll let those
set up for about an hour and a half to
two hours on a good day and then they're
ready to actually put on a car or truck
during a pit stop
so in this view you'll see where the
driver can also help the pit crew in a
pit stop we generally call him the sixth
man on the pit crew them hitting their
marks can really help speed the pit stop
up we'll have sign board out there so
they can see their box coming in they
know to put that left headlight on the
sign board to always hit that mark that
helps us a lot right off the get go so
we can start to pre-plan where the car
is going to be also as they're coming in
making sure that not only they brake on
that mark but when they're braking to go
ahead and get the wheel straight we've
been doing this for years where we put
tape on the steering wheel which will be
right at 12 o'clock so that way when the
driver has the wheel straight that
allows the wheels the hubs actually be
straight which allows us to hit lug nuts
off and to put tires on and off the
fronts of the car because if that wheel
is turned it's really tough to hit lugs
and it's really hard to get the tire off
another thing to do in all stops is you
gotta realize when they're coming in
that they're generally gonna be in
second gear maybe third gear breaking
its stop but they have to get back into
first gear before they leave out of
their pit box while you're trying to hit
a lug nut or trying to put a will in the
car the last thing you want to have
happen is those studs move on you so
drivers know once they stop keep the car
in gear and once we drop the car on the
right side they'll go ahead and shift
while the car is on the ground to put it
back in first gear as soon as they feel
that car dropped they know to get the
car back out of the pit box that is
their timer
i'd like to show you a few tools that us
pick crew people use to pit the car
one of the heaviest pieces you'll see on
pit road is the fuel can you'll see that
fuels are normally larger in stature
they're a little bit taller than normal
one to line this probe up
to the car itself to line that up and
get it flush you need to joint be about
six foot tall the can itself when it's
filled with fuel can be on the upwards
of 110 pounds here like some teams do
we'll utilize water to mimic fueling one
it's safer two all of our cars will have
reservoirs where the water will run into
so the water doesn't go into the fuel
tank or go to the engine one of the
tools we use is changers is an impact
wrench probably one of the tools that i
think most people know the sound of
a lot of people when they learn how to
do pit stops this is what the position
they at least want to learn how to try
and do first these are a little bit more
efficient a lot more faster than your
standard shop tool we're running
generally upwards of 200 pounds of
nitrogen to actually spin that socket so
that allows us to get these lug nuts off
a little more efficient and quicker than
standard shop guns there's a coupling in
that goes to the whip hose into the gun
this will always run to a nitrogen
bottle that nitrogen bottle puts
nitrogen through this hose through the
whip hose into the impact wrench the
nitrogen is what spins the internals of
this gun and allows that socket to spin
freely we have to keep these internals
always oiled up bare minimum we always
change all at least every two stops we
put just enough oil in there to fill up
the internals of that gun you always
check to make sure it free spins when
you're spinning with your hand make sure
you definitely have a clean snap on your
button switches it should have a nice
firm click to it
so this is a linered tire which means it
has a bladder within the tire itself so
this is a 90-pound tire we also run
things called non-liners where it's just
the tire there's no bladder inside those
are generally about 55 to 60 pounds so
depending on what track we're at we'll
run different style tires and
wheels to become a picture member it
takes a lot of heart drive and intensity
teaching the fundamentals to anyone is
not the hard part it's getting an
individual who wants it who doesn't mind
grinding day in day out repeating the
same movements to fine-tune those steps
to get better each and every day
sometimes only gaining one percent each
time they practice you don't want to
race without a pit crew
you